thank you
[Music]
all right we're gonna we're gonna take
this moment and uh we're gonna let Bart
have the floor for a bit because yeah I
have a far bar
kind of owes uh a public apology oh I do
this time for his actions at a Taiwan
7-Eleven
um Bart you want to go ahead and give us
some context of what you did here I won
holes yeah
he's wearing your [__] shorts too
oh dude
why'd you do it someone
took the last
[__] marinated uh tea eggs
implanted that in your head dude this
guy's business the the dawn eggs yeah
yeah I was thinking that and you [__]
said it oh really yeah you guys business
partner no I telepathically threw that
[__] in there that's pretty good yeah
but that is one of my favorite things
about so the 7-Elevens in Taiwan it's so
good there's like like you know our hot
food section is like pizza hot dogs
whatever yeah yeah they have like Asian
food corner and it's like it's good like
you got fried tofu all kinds of stuff
what about the stinky do I got a stinky
one unfortunately
thank God they don't was probably the
most frequently sent clip to the JK
accounts ever like everybody like mill
like so many people were just like is
this bar is this bar is it like all day
his like back silhouette profiles he
really does look like me though
I've seen Bart wear those shorts before
absolutely so what we're gonna do today
is we are going to um have Jesse rate
how accurate some of these doppelgangers
are to how we look oh get ready for your
feelings to be hurt all right so this
one
how do we feel about that this is
supposed to be Steve
no no does it match you don't see
there's way too much hair I see the eyes
a little bit and it's supposed to be
Nick with long hair
with long hair more degrees that's not
me closer it is I think so it's like a
light skin she's the final say it's it's
nickel slave he looks like he's a
deflector too like yeah yeah hands on
his hips yeah but he's like the he's
like the Romantic Nick not seriously
he's like this shirt's gay he's like
this shirt's gay
that was good all right what what this
one bisexual twins that's supposed to
just be chill
that's really good a little bit
that's really good I think Joe's
prettier do you have your glasses around
here this just looks like a like a
gender swap like an app it also looks
like Jimmy all young too yeah oh yeah it
does look like that looks more like
Julia
Steve Green's baby Steve make that face
before let's see that I could definitely
see that for some reason there's a we
get a lot of babies for cities yeah I
made a baby by himself that would be me
direct clone you know
a 100 me baby yeah that look like them
it does all right here we got uh Joe
looks like Cherry Cola it's mostly they
look like they could be related yeah
it's most yeah
pretty good
all right uh which one is Steve
those are just white dudes man
those guys could be cousins for sure
yeah thank you let me see just a lot of
just white dudes for Steve as well I was
like that's Stephen come on dude which
one of these guys looks like in the most
I think the one in the white yeah yeah
along the way the side profile yeah but
if you look at them straight on he might
be completely different
that's funny
um okay that says the guy on the left
asking Gwen Stefani for an autograph
looks like Steve if he had Luscious Hair
yeah
yeah it doesn't look like that doesn't
look like Steve the biggest difference I
can see where they're coming from sorry
guys see how they just see a white guy
and they go that's probably Steve yeah
like Glenn Stefani looks like Steve he's
a woman Indian Ryan sorry Ryan
that's pretty good that frame of him
doing that I've seen you do that I think
about that T-shirt and the clothing yeah
the clothing see me do what this You See
Me freeze frame I look like a lot of
Indian guys apparently
uh if Joe and Nick had a baby I see the
Joe for sure yeah wait this is a panty
that's pretty cool that's Joe's that's
Joe's face on my head yeah that's a real
existing human you guys should with my
gestures you need to check 23. yeah with
my gestures those are that's a nickname
gesture uh that's just Joe
that's can't it's just candy that's
Canon yeah it's more Ken oh yeah I guess
like on the face yeah yeah that's pretty
good uh there's Steve as a kid it's
pretty accurate that's just the white
kid crying down a slide yeah
but you you could also tell this kid's a
tall kid yeah oh my God he's a cool kid
I did crawl I did cry going up the slide
though why because it was burning hot in
the sun
burning my kneecaps I do it up all right
is this Ryan just an Indian guy oh sexy
Indian guy yeah that's kind of that's
kind of you I think so sexy because he's
Indian he doesn't look like you but he
kind of resembles you with that oh he
has the same he has Ryan buys yeah his
shirt he's shirtless in the dark
there's no float of me anywhere near
this but he looks like a second it's
just a mustache it's a mustache and
eyebrows
I'll take his comp well that's pretty
much me that's black Ryan that is not
you at all from the other video is that
the guy who's going like this yeah I
think it's the same guy uh if Bart was
black
[Laughter]
yeah I don't know
the eyebrows are spot on this guy's head
is insanely Square the eyebrows are spot
on though the head shape the head shape
okay like I could see the resemblance of
the head shape but it's
that's the black guy version of your
haircut
when I need to [__] get a lifeline on
this [__] [__] [__] get a
Lifeline she's gonna call Geo
she's gonna be like that guy
FaceTime this and talk it's a Lifeline
okay
does this
like me it follows black
no
her head like yours see I told you the
head Geo eyebrows though what about the
eyebrows what about the eyebrows
oh no those are nice eyebrows what
he has one eyebrow
[__] regret calling you I'll talk to
you later no you're you're out of here
[__]
[Laughter]
Bros being guys next time we shoot
Bart's gonna have darker eyebrows
could be elephant
oh dude do it someone got their eyebrows
limited
he's just always covered his eyebrows
first thing he gets home close the door
hey do I really not have eyebrows
all right this is Anthony it's an
Anthony ad does that look like why does
he get the wholesome ones dude like he's
the baby or he's the dad where is he
this one is probably not as spot-on as
the other one okay so as much as we get
a bunch of just regular white guys that
people claim this look like Steve we get
a lot of random Asian guys that look
like this Anthony
that's what this is why that's that's
what I see
let's spot on right come on
that's
you know I don't think that looks like
Anthony
straight trash
uh here we got Nick
he does look he does look like Nick
though every time there's a photo this
guy it comes out people send it to JK
Jesse go a little pressure no pressure
If you say yes I'll walk into traffic
right now
I was about to say yes
go like this
yeah do this open your eyes yeah look
straight in the camera please right
there oh okay Photoshop my hands out
dude the best [__] Nick walking into
traffic would get hit by basically Nick
because Nick's like what's this [__]
guy doing in traffic he might as well
get run over step on it and then Nick's
the guy in traffic he's like I'm in the
[__] guy in traffic yeah so so Ral
roses he's a popular fighter yeah yeah
and he's got your ears dude anytime he
fights I feel like I'm fighting or
something is everyone just like sending
it to me it says after was watching a
scene from Rambo 2 and suddenly came
across an Anthony variant
[Music]
that's when he's like being focused it's
just Sergeant Kendra's is a hashtag
that's more of a can like Anthony all
right this one's Joe in the background
of Barry oh yeah
because I saw this when I was watching
the show I really thought it was
interesting that one's a really close
one uh Steve is wild
it's a white guy
[__] hey we got a lot of racial
followers
um and here's Anthony Lee variant in
Bangkok yeah that one that's a variant
for sure that's a good Anthony
that's a chub Anthony what about this
Anthony
what is that like orange [__] I just
looked up Anthony Lee on Google Images
it's so crazy
[Laughter]
all right uh this one just says damn
Anthony Lee looking good which I think
is just a distal Anthony well dressed
man which one is he supposed to yeah I
don't get it the guy on the right
people really put effort into finding
yours for sure
um this is Joe I guess just regular Joe
that's my friend
we went and caught crab
crab fishing nobody know this guy yeah
that's Chef Khalid do people get you
guys confused
uh well they said that when we did the
video together they thought that we were
brothers
that's pretty cool yeah I could see that
one uh there's Nick again that guy I did
thank you which rose this guy does we
get a lot of this he does look like yeah
he does he looks like your big brother
have you ever seen his stuff yeah I've
seen the stuff he eats with his son or
brother or son and they eat yummy food
all the time yeah and I'm like what a
dream job it's pretty cute yeah yeah he
um I actually asked him if he would come
on he said he's down and he said he said
that uh you guys should sit together I
would I'll sit next to him can we eat
something together yeah can we do that
that'd be really cool and then we have
yeah
oh
he does have Joe's face yeah bro he got
Joe's face
all caps Dr Phil got like a 12-pack yeah
that's insane uh there he is again [__]
does look like Joe though
so yeah there you go for your goals you
want to put that myself
I think is that the last one oh wait no
we got Nick on a poison ivy cream that's
me that does look like Nick that's me
dude what do you think wait which one
all of them all three of them all three
the most swollen one would be him dude I
can get pretty swollen I don't know if
you notice that's not a bragging right
Steve
but I'm gonna kill myself
it's time to end it all hey at least you
weren't the swollen cream guy that's
true what's wrong with being that guy oh
you're Steve again
uh yeah it's time to end my life me and
Steve are gonna walk into traffic
together hey we had a good run this it
says why is this fool look like a white
Mexican version of Anthony
it's just a gold tea I think apparently
it's the style the jacket all right
that's it it's more lid
more lit
stupid
foreign